we're gonna focus on something getting
talked about a lot these days
impeachment it's one of the most
consequential decisions a legislature
can make but more importantly it's also
an anagram for pinch-me meat which is
interestingly these centers that got the
Lucky Charms leprechaun me too now ever
since this president got elected people
have been dying to see him impeached
sometimes literally as this oddly upbeat
Inside Edition clip shows two people who
passed away recently died happily after
being led to believe President Donald
Trump was impeached according to the
obituary for Corliss Gilchrist from Des
Moines Iowa loved ones told him before
he died that Trump's impeachment process
had begun so he would rest in peace
further west in Oregon loved ones say
this man 75 year old Michael Elliot
passed away peacefully last month as
soon as they told him Trump had been
impeached great music choice there to
cover two old men dying perfect tone you
set although I will say this that's
actually a sweet gesture from their
families but why stop there
hey Dad we all love you very much and we
just wanted to tell you Donald Trump has
been impeached arrested registered as a
sex offender stuffed into a tie by
robert muller and rolled into the
Potomac River
he got so dizzy he cried and hurled and
himself all at the same time
they've got it all on camera and now
it's a meme anyway have a good death
goodbye but the question of in
Pittsburgh hasn't just been employed as
effective hospice care it's become a
major talking point among House
Democrats with a rising number coming
out in favor of it 63 of them now
support an impeachment inquiry and some
like representative Rasheeda Talib have
gone even further we're gonna go I know
running teach the
Wow it is genuinely startling to hear
that language from a congressperson what
almost sooner expect to hear impeach the
as an edgy new slogan for
peach iced tea Oh Snapple
you were always the nice tea this isn't
you but not everyone in the Democratic
Party is quite as
enthusiastic about the whole impeachment
idea House Speaker Nancy Pelosi has
repeatedly attempt to apply the brakes
to an impeachment inquiry claiming the
country is not behind it and then in
fact they barely understand what it
actually means do you know most people
think that impeachment means you're out
of office did you ever get that feeling
are you just in the bubble here they
think that you get a peach you're gone
and that is completely not true it's not
the means to the end that people think
all you do vote to impeach bye-bye
birdie it isn't that
non-si Pelosi knows there there's simply
no better way to connect with the
average working job than by referencing
a Broadway musical from 1960 also if
this situation were to be a musical it
wouldn't be Bye Bye Birdie it would
obviously be grease where a rapey guy
with weird hair treats women like
and yet somehow gets everything he's
ever wanted but I will say it is true
that many people don't fully understand
what impeachment involves so what we
thought that tonight might be a good
time to discuss what it is why it may be
warranted and what the risks might be in
carrying it out and let's start with the
fact that as Nancy Pelosi just said
impeachment in no way guarantees a
president's removal from office in fact
no president has ever actually been
removed through this process two
presidents have been impeached clinton
and johnson but remained in office and
nixon actually resigned on his own
before the house could finish impeaching
him sort of like an Irish goodbye if
Nixon didn't also hate the Irish very
basically here is how the impeachment
process works typically it begins with
an inquiry in the House of
Representatives during which a committee
investigates and holds hearings into a
president's conduct and if a majority
decides they found impeachable offenses
they vote to
but that is not the end that merely
moves the process to the Senate where a
trial is held and the president is only
removed from office if a two-thirds
majority votes for that so what is the
case for putting this president through
that process well the Constitution says
grounds for impeachment are treason
bribery or high crimes and misdemeanors
and that last phrase can trip people up
even people who might really want to
research its exact definition there was
no crime you know it's high crime and
not width or for its high crimes and
misdemeanors there was no high crime and
there was no misdemeanor so how do you
have each based on that okay okay
clearly high crimes and misdemeanors
doesn't literally mean there has to be
both a big crime and a little crime well
the president's committed murder now we
just need to catch him urinating on the
side of the wall ah
and we got it no that's not how anything
works because if the fact is high crimes
and misdemeanors can include acts that
are not actual crimes
it is a broad term for serious
misconduct and Congress is currently
looking into a wide range of trumps
potential misconduct from a campaign
finance violations to whether or not
he's used his office to enrich himself
but one area where we already have
considerable evidence against Trump is
obstruction of justice it's a very
serious allegation it was among the
articles of impeachment approved against
both Nixon and Clinton obstruction was
also half of Robert Mueller's report in
which he laid out ten potential
instances of it taking place and we
clearly don't have time to get into all
ten so let's let's just look at one
involving Don Magan who was Trump's
White House Counsel you might remember
him as well as the understudy for Brett
Kavanaugh during his confirmation
hearing he was ready to jump in if
Cavanaugh ever cried himself into an
early nap
McCann's appearance in the Miller report
got a lot of attention when it first
came out primarily because of one eye
catching quotes former White House
Counsel Dunn McGann he refused to ask
rod Rosenstein to fire Muller and
threatened to resign instead after the
president asked him to do quote crazy
using a word that I can't use on TV the
word is the word in question is
Tom McGann said the President and I
quote asked him to do crazy and
it's frankly amazing that in a time when
norms are crumbling left and right we
are upholding the norm that Ali Velshi
can't say on MSNBC I guess that
does actually make sense kids love the
village there's there's nothing
four-year-olds love more than watching
him on TV and repeating everything the
velch says but that phrase crazy
actually became unhelpfully distracting
because the fact the president's lawyer
said a naughty word kept people from
focusing on the details of what Trump
actually asked him to do which many
argue amounted to flagrant obstruction
Trump asked McGann to have Robert mullah
the person investigating him fired
specifically according to McGann under
oath Trump told him mullah has to go
adding call me back when you do it then
calling him back and asking have you
done it so this is clearly something
very important to Trump it wasn't
something he said casually like Robert
Pattinson should not take back Kristen
Stewart she cheated on him like a dog or
my favorite part of Pulp fix is when Sam
has his gun out in the diner and he
tells the girl tells the guy to tell his
girlfriend to shut up tell that to
be cool say be cool I love those
lines
no this was something trunk was really
serious about but the potential
obstruction didn't stop there because a
second instance mullah sighted came
after news broke the Trump had tried to
remove mullah and Trump tried to get
Magan to put out a statement denying it
and also said he wanted began to write a
letter to that effect for our records
so to recap there it seems the president
obstructed justice then obstructed
justice again to try to obstruct the
investigation into his obstruction of
justice it's ridiculous I know I know
that this might seem like a legal
technicality in a couple of phone calls
that didn't go anywhere but here's why
this really matters but for Don Magan
trunk might have stopped an
investigation into himself and if a
president can shut down an investigation
he can basically do anything with no
consequences it's a big big deal the
problem is this has been in the public
record for nearly two months now and his
failed to make much of an impression
when Justin Amash the the only House
Republican to come out in favor of
impeachment so far held a town hall
where he explained his decision at least
one of his attendees was genuinely
shocked to hear that Trump might have
done anything wrong I was surprised to
hear there was anything negative in the
malla report at all about President
Trump I hadn't heard that before and I
mainly listened to conservative news
I haven't heard anything negative about
that report and president Trump has been
exonerated yeah that's what will happen
when you mainly listen to conservative
news it's like your only source of
information about Oh Jay Simpson it's
his new Twitter account yeah that's real
the juice is on Twitter now and if that
was your only source of juice news you
might not understand why this first
video that he posted is so alarming now
coming soon to Twitter you'll get to
read all my thoughts and opinions on
just about everything
so it should be a lot of fun I got a
little didn't even to do oh my god what
is getting even mean for O'Shea when you
kill two people you even three people
your odds for people yet even again is
that it I don't know but the point I'm
making is if that's the only place
you're getting your oj info your
response to that video might be Oh Jay
looks great he's 71 whatever he's been
doing it works but but that woman is by
no means alone the truth is most people
are simply never going to read a four
hundred and forty eight page legal
document that is presumably why Congress
has been trying to have public hearings
to get that information out in a way
that might resonate with people better
in fact Magan was called to publicly
testify last month which could have been
very powerful and I'm guessing that's
why this happened instead former White
House Counsel Don Magan was a no-show at
a house hearing today after the
president insisted he'd not testify
Democrats had hopes to hear from former
White House Counsel Don Magan instead
they were faced with this empty chair
great so Democrats tried to have a
hearing but instead had pass over they
put out a chair for a guest who didn't
arrive and most of America had no idea
that it happened look there is a real
argument to be made here for
concentrating Congress's investigations
and the public's attention into one
impeachment inquiry so why not do it
well Nancy Pelosi might argue that
impeachment is not popular with the
public which is to be fair true polls
consistently show a majority of
Americans oppose impeachment proceedings
although it is not quite that simple
remember most people don't
even know what is in the mullah report
and numbers can move as people learn
more look at Nixon in hindsight his
resignation seems inevitable but in the
early days of the scandal there was real
public resistance to his removal many
more things are bothering America than
Watergate I think they make a big fuss
over nothing nothing has been proven
illegal about anything he's done and I
think he's he's on the right track yeah
exactly
for a while people thought that
Watergate the scandal that we now use a
shorthand for every political scandal
didn't matter and that that's shocking
to watch although to be fair in the
1970s they also thought that shag
carpeting was attractive and that
Liberace just hadn't met the right girl
yet that decades had a lot to learn but
but a Nixon outcome is not the only
model many Democrats worry that things
could instead end up like the Clinton
impeachment where the public wasn't
really on board with impeachment from
the beginning and they never got on
board and not only did Clinton survive
his party gained seats in that year's
midterms that is what Democrats are
scared about here that that impeachment
could end up strengthening Trump for
2020 although for any Democrats whose
main concern is that pursuing
impeachment could be the reason they
lose in 2020 please relax it's just one
of many ways the Democrats could lose
maybe Trump is caught on tape saying the
n-word but then two weeks later
Elizabeth Warren accidentally caused a
veteran a veterinarian and people get
twice as angry about that there's so
many ways that this could go wrong so so
for so many people here that the key
calculation is would the benefits of
impeachment outweigh the risks and look
that is just impossible to say it's
impossible to say how a trump
impeachment would play out although him
leaving office is extremely unlikely
that that would require 20 Republican
senators to vote against him and even if
they did that there is still no
guarantee that Trump would actually
leave he basically told us as much out
loud when you look at past impeachment
where there was president litt nor I
guess
President Nixon never got there he left
I don't leave there's a big difference I
don't leave yeah
of course Trump wouldn't leave you think
he'd hold a press conference and
bashfully saying to a camera I was wrong
in what reality would that happen then
you graciously say I would now let
someone else be the president you're
insane
then what he pack a suitcase and walk
physically walk out of the White House
and just not be the president anymore
no he make us drag him out like an
uncooperative toddler you know this you
know that's true and if you're thinking
what if he's unlikely to go then what's
the point
well it might be helpful to stop
thinking of this in purely binary terms
you know if the president goes well
that's a success if he stays it's a
failure
basically it's Nixon or it's Clinton
that's a false choice it's like saying
you can only be Hufflepuff or Slytherin
excuse me
Gryffindor and ravenclaw are right there
and in my case snuggle boggle that's
that's the fifth Hogwarts house that's
exclusively for cowards because because
when it comes to impeachment there
aren't just two outcomes even if Trump
is not removed which he probably won't
be the process could shine a light on
the contents of the Malheur report
potentially lead to new revelations
about Trump's conduct and forces
Republican allies to choose publicly and
on the record whether or not to hold him
to account and you might well say but
even so opening an impeachment inquiry
is just too risky and I do get that I've
gone back and forth on this myself for
that very reason and to be honest the
thing that's tipped the scales for me is
remembering that not opening an inquiry
comes with consequences too because it
essentially sends the message that the
president can act with impunity which is
a dangerous precedent to set not just
for future presidents but for the
current one just this week he was asked
about Don juniors failure to alert the
FBI when Russia offered them Intel
during the campaign and his response was
appalling
shouldn't he are going to the FBI when
he got there okay let's put yourself in
a position you're a congressman somebody
comes up and says hey I have information
on Europe on
do you call the FBI I don't think I mean
from the night one you do I've seen a
lot of things over my life I don't think
in my whole life I've ever called the
FBI in my whole life I don't you don't
call the FBI this is somebody that said
we have information on your opponent
oh let me call the FBI give me a break
life doesn't work or director says
that's what should happen the FBI
director is wrong okay there is so much
in there let's break this down into
three pieces first I don't think in my
whole life I've ever called the FBI is a
truly insane thing to say no people
usually don't call the FBI except when
they're in a very specific situation
that clearly requires them to do so
that's kind of how that works I have
never called Emilio Estevez as a general
rule in one's everyday life one does not
call Emilio Estevez but if I found a
wallet on the street with Emilio Estevez
his driver's license and contact
information on call Emilio
Estevez because that's what the
situation requires okay so second let's
take he's give me a break
life doesn't work that way it is
genuinely fascinating to watch Trump
project his own amoral awfulness onto
the rest of humanity
oh so you see a baby stroller about to
roll down a hill and what you're gonna
stop it give me a break life doesn't
work out that way you stand there your
watch and you laugh everybody knows this
and everybody agrees give me a break
give me a break or that one and finally
the FBI director is wrong he's basically
saying laws are a matter of opinion and
you can trust your uncle Don on this one
but of course that is not true which is
why the head of the Federal Election
Commission put out a statement reminding
all of us that it is illegal to accept
anything of value from a foreign country
in connection with the u.s. election and
when foreign governments seek to
influence American politics it is always
to advance their own interests not
America's she tweeted that statement out
with a note reading I would not have
thought that I needed to say this
that kind of sums up where we are in the
Trump presidency all of those things we
wouldn't have thought we needed to say
we need to say them now and as
if that weren't bad enough Trump been
engaged in a little thought experiment
of what he would do if he found himself
in the same situation all over again
your campaign this time around if
foreigners if Russia if China if someone
else offers you information an opponent
should they accept it or should they
call the FBI I think maybe you do both I
think you might want to listen I don't
there's nothing wrong with listening if
somebody called from a country Norway we
have information on your opponent oh I
think I'd want to hear you want that
kind of interference in our elections
it's not an interference they have
information I think I'd take it
first of all let's address that Norway
it continues to be telling that when
Trump tries to search his brain for the
best country he can imagine it goes
directly to the whitest country he can
imagine but but more importantly that is
the president openly inviting foreign
interference in our elections again and
I know that we've all become numb to
Trump by this point but moments like
that really shock you out of your stupor
and make you think oh oh hang on that
guy's got to be impeached we've got to
impeach him and look should Democrats
let house investigations play out a
little further before they make a move I
don't maybe there's an argument for that
that strategy certainly paid off during
Watergate but later can't mean never
because the case for inaction here is
starting to get pretty weak and yes
public opinion is currently against an
impeachment inquiry but if Democrats
think opening an inquiry is genuinely
the right thing to do then it's then
incumbent upon them to work to change
that opinion I know it's easy to be
defeatist here because nothing has
seemingly reined Trump in so far but I
will say this every succeeds
until finally they don't again 18 months
before he resigned Nixon had a sky-high
approval rating of 67 percent Harvey
Weinstein was winning Oscars until one
day he definitely wasn't
James Holzhauer was stealing all of Alex
Trebek's money until someone finally put
a stop to it respects the spirit of the
game James yeah monster I can't
guarantee that impeachment will work out
the way that you wanted to because it
probably won't but that doesn't mean
that it's not worth doing because if
nothing else we'd be standing by the
basic fundamental principle that nobody
is above the law and in doing so it
would mean that when people tell dying
relatives that we're doing everything we
can to hold this president accountable
at least this time it would actually be
true
you